what up though the new album is coming
out next week yeah October 20th Stuck In
Motion Stuck In Motion I just saw um
this the first video coming out with
Larry June yeah just came dropped just
dropped shout out to Larry June man yeah
shout out bro man yeah um you know I do
feel like uh you have been like such a
Powerhouse in in Hip Hop for so long
especially when it comes to just like
doing it the Texas way independent you
know what I'm saying yeah and it feels
like the last like two or three years
you finally for whatever reason just
started to kind of get your flowers I
think I just saw you on Joe Rogan so if
I my feel if someone's on Joe Rogan it's
the biggest platform in the world shout
out Joe that's my brother man but do you
feel that like do you feel like finally
like you've always had your respect
within hip-hop you've always had your
respect within obviously the whole South
um TR a has been just a movie for how
many years now over a decade yeah years
but do you feel like recently you
finally kind of started to get
recognized from like more of The
Gatekeepers more of like the you had a
pretty uphill battle you know especially
coming out of where you're from and I'm
I'm still having that battle but um I
think God just he he opening the lane
for me but I think he doing it at his
pace
so how big I'm going to get I Ain I
haven't got there yet but he I'm on the
uphill climb still right now and he you
know he's doing different things to let
me know it's not a point of giving up
it's not option just like little things
happen that keep you going like you know
what I'm on the right Mission like I got
to keep going yeah definitely man and um
you know it's just all kind of crazy
things happening the left and right in a
good way you know so I'm grateful man um
how did you end up on the Rogan podcast
like how like who connected that um he's
had J Prince on he's had will Dion he's
I mean obviously he's a hip-hop guy yeah
Joe Joe's you know that's family that's
like my brother but you know I'm tied in
with the UFC okay so you know Dana's my
that me and Dana White real close and
just the whole staff oh you guys talked
about that too like the uh what's the
big the big fighter I'm not a big U you
yeah the Beast you guys had
him yeah the Beast um Dustin poer
um Kevin Holland um man it's so it's so
many of them I'm tied into but you know
I have a actual life deal with UFC cuz
you know we have UFC bump boxes you
listen you got everything bump boxes
people win the Super Bowl they got a
bump box Debo Samuels running around
with a bump box everybody's got listen
if people don't understand like and and
I I I'm not being paid to say this not
cuz you're here I tell this to people
all of the time do not waste your
[__] money on any of these three four
$500 [__] Bluetooth speakers
the bump box is crazy yeah yeah it is
crazy and we man you know we just
released a new version which is the
remix that um look like the cassette
tape yeah um you just showed me it looks
crazy I I think the one I have is called
a flare eight yeah yeah yeah we still
got all those we got we got the um we
got so many different ones you know we
did the deal with the gronowski so we
got Shaker cups that got the speakers on
them now too like a cup yeah the Shaker
cups yeah like
mhm um you know our headphones coming um
you familiar what a cornhole is yeah
cornhole yeah so you know any cornhole
that has a speaker on it we own the
rights to it so we have the new cornhole
bump boxes so one of my best friends his
best friend well his one of his best
friends is the guy from SWAT the
beautiful uh baldheaded man what's his
name you know his name Shamar Shamar
Moore yeah and he's a part of the
cornhole League oh yeah I'm have to Mo
is yeah I I we don't know each other but
I'll find them and make sure we get no
so he has like um in his backyard ESPN
oo or whatever ESPN number will
broadcast the cornhole competition but
it's ESPN um they like he has a whole
like real cornhole like arena in his
backyard you you know somebody who know
him yeah so put me with him yeah we'll
FaceTime him now yeah I'll show you how
it work yeah cornhole [__] is booming
right now you need to get a hold of you
know what else is popping right now that
everybody's doing and I don't know why
but have you heard of pickle ball no
pickle ball is like the new [__] way
like overweight dudes who like don't
want to work out work out cuz they're
like yo it's
fun and I burn calories but it's not
like you know running in place pickle
ball uh what what is
that I just know there's a paddle and I
know
that there's a rapper who owns a team a
smaller version of tennis
yeah small Katie is a part owner of the
team in New York there's a pickle ball
uh League that just started and Kevin
Durant I think is one of the owners no
he is one of the owners of the uh oh
yeah shout out my bro Katie yeah you got
to get locked in yeah I wonder like you
always hear about the Joe Rogan Spike
you go on the show do you see spikes in
analytics followers music goes up
everything goes up or or I I haven't
even I ain't really paid attention cuz
I've been moving nonstop yeah you've
been moving non-stop yeah you're in
album mode but I what I will say
is different people who ain't who ain't
necessarily familiar with my music and
other stuff when they see me they like
man I just seen you on Joe Rogan uh
podcast yeah you know what I'm saying so
definitely a blessing but I know one
time Joe posted the bump box and I know
that day alone was some crazy numbers
sold yeah yeah yeah for sure for sure
man that shit's dope congrats on B has
anybody tried to come and uh buy you
guys out yet like a bigger company you
know know they have but we worth so much
now like we why do it yeah yeah and if
we do it's going to have to make sense
like it's going to have to be like apple
or something crazy like yeah it it have
to be something crazy and I would still
be tied into it because we built that
from yeah you guys have Sweat Equity but
you also have like personal Equity into
the company yeah do you guys still have
the store in Riverside uh there was that
you guys had a like a flagship store
yeah I'm not I'm not sure because you
know we had of course we had the one in
Houston and the Galleria but it it got
to the point
we don't even need the stores like it's
online so crazy you know why have the
brick and mortar if you don't need it
yeah yeah but it was dope to to do you
know just to be able to do that and um
but right now it's just it's going like
if you look in the Barbie movie we in
there yeah I I saw that yeah you so we
just we're a little bit of everywhere
man did you think like obviously you
believed in bump box but it's crazy
because it's like I remember I used to
always just associate bump box with you
cuz that's how I found out about it
right but it's transcended it and it's
so like you said it's in the biggest
movie ever yeah yeah um like did you
ever have any idea would get this big
honestly no you know it's still it's
still excitement there that that we
growing like when my you know we had the
headphones the waves that came out now
we got the N the in ear headphones
that's about to drop too hey whatever
headphone company you were involved with
I still have those headphones yeah that
was that's that was them okay I still
have those but now we got the N ones and
they Bluetooth wireless yeah yeah
everything man oh yeah you guys are we
going we going to crush it for sure um
uh we got something called a slap stick
too
and like you can put it on anything
metal it'll it'll stick to it and um
it's a Bluetooth radio loud as hell you
know what I'm saying like we got it's
almost like a magnet you just slap it
places like if you're like sh if you're
working on cars yep shower any any
anything yeah anything metal yeah it's
waterproof uh I would say for the most
part yeah yeah yeah it's waterproof
enough yeah yeah for sure sick